against all advice i did work full-time
during my first three years of studying
medicine at university and although i'm
not going to get into whether that was
the best decision in the world in this
video today as you can imagine it did
mean that when it came to completing
university projects i didn't always have
the luxury of time so whether i liked it
or not i did have to come up with
systems to do things fastly efficiently
and without procrastinating
now although i definitely do not condone
leaving things to the last minute i do
agree that systems do make things that
are not so enjoyable be a lot more
efficient and therefore fun today i
wanted to share the exact system that i
used to write good university essays in
under three hours by doing a full
walkthrough of an essay with you here so
i have my computer in front of me and
let's get started so first things first
i am going to be using notion this is
because it is literally the best app in
the world i have a whole second brain on
it if you want to check that out there's
a video somewhere if you're into that
but basically notion is free it's clean
it's effective it's absolutely in my
opinion the best app for students now
you can probably use the system with
something else but i'm going to be doing
my walkthrough in notion i'll break down
every single step in a way that should
hopefully be easy to replicate so let's
say our essay title is the importance of
teaching skills in medical professional
practice this is an essay i had to write
last year the first thing i'm going to
do is create a database page on notion
now this sounds really complicated all
it really is is a table so it's quite
easy to work with now the reason i do
this is because i absolutely hate
writing essays top to bottom i actually
write them left to right and i'm going
to explain how this happens i think it's
a hugely heavy lift to write a full
essay so i kind of break it up into very
many small bits the first breakup that i
will do is obviously an introduction
body and conclusion because we have to
start write and wrap up our essay now
there's an extra step that i do here
that i feel is very important i feel an
easy way that people lose points with
their essays is not looking at the
marking scheme and no matter how
elaborate beautiful how many amazing
points you make and how many great
quotes that you use in your essay if you
are not taking all of the criteria in
the marking points you are obviously
going to lose a lot of marks and on the
flip side if you take every single point
in the marking scheme even if you
haven't written an amazing essay you are
guaranteed a pass or even a really good
mark so i go to the marketing scheme and
make sure i do all of them sometimes i
have essays which don't have such a
delicate marking scheme and in this case
i will have to come up with it myself
okay what do i think this professor
would like to assess me on and i put
those points in the body this should
take about five to ten minutes depending
on if you are copy pasting these from
somewhere else or if i'm just spending a
few minutes kind of trying to come up
with them myself i don't spend a lot of
time on this part step number two is
when we start to branch out a bit so
i'll be thinking about the introduction
itself this is where i set the scene for
the essay the way that i imagine
introductions is like
i'm having a conversation with someone
who's in front of me who does not know
the title of my essay and i'm not
allowed to say the title of my essay but
i can talk about whatever so i just kind
of set the context in a way that i
try to make the person ask the question
which is the title of the essay itself
if that makes any sense and if you can
write from mind around that so in this
case i think i'm going to start by
writing why it's important for a doctor
to be a teacher and that's going to be
my first paragraph and my second
paragraph is going to talk about why i'm
writing this essay at all and kind of
the experiences that i did and i think
this would be fine for the introduction
now within the body i'm going to go to
every single assessment point and create
an aim for every single paragraph and
some of these assessment points won't
stand on paragraphs as their own so i'll
just kind of remove them some of them i
might want to merge together but for
every single one i'm going to see if
they can stand as a future paragraph so
for the conclusion i do the exact same
thing i think i want to end this essay
by talking about the wider context of
higher education and its implications
for professional medical practice then
i'm also going to talk about somehow how
this experience has changed me um this
column two is now done and this should
take about 20 minutes i think to kind of
make these points and clean these things
up it's only about 10 sentences that i'm
actually writing but it does take a bit
of thinking time step number three is
where we start to have fun for every
single aim i created i'm going to make a
central core argument for each paragraph
i think where essays don't look very
good is where paragraphs are quite
wishy-washy and when i read them i'm not
sure what they're saying or what point
they are trying to make so trying to
approach it from the other way around
where you make the central point of the
paragraph first and then you build the
paragraph ensures that everything that
you're writing has a central aim and is
very coherent and logical so for every
single aim and this can be either the
marking criteria or it can be the things
that i put in the introduction and
conclusion i am going to make one single
argument and these arguments don't all
have to come from my brain very often i
like using quotes here i like using
studies i like using kind of experiences
of my own so it can be very different
things i cheat on this point because i
have a second brain so i have all of
these quotes and studies in one place
already so i've had to double the time
that it takes me to do this in this
three hour estimation for example if i
want to talk about the importance of
being a doctor in medicine i like this
richard feynman quote which says a young
man doesn't realize how much time it
takes to prepare good lectures for the
first time especially it kind of talks
about how students or people who haven't
talked before don't appreciate how
difficult and important education is and
therefore i think this is a quote for
someone famous it is written well and it
also makes a good point so i'm going to
be using this quote as my central
argument for my first paragraph and i'll
do the same thing for every single other
paragraph i spend a lot of time on
pubmed here trying to find studies that
have findings or explorations which are
relevant to the points that i want to
make in my study and very importantly
here i'll also add another column with
the sources so for every single quote or
every single study i will have the full
source of it so i can use it in my kind
of resources in the end of my essay so
for me this takes maximum half an hour
but i can see how it can take up to an
hour so at this point we have done one
and a half hour of our essay writing
already and this is where we get to step
number four and this is the only time
where i actually start writing the words
of my essay and why i find the system
works so well is because if i were to
start from scratch i would have to write
kind of a whole essay based on nothing
but because i have all of these kind of
rows done what that means is that it's
kind of like i have someone who's just
prepared most of my essay for me already
and i don't have to write a full essay
all i have to write is paragraphs based
on a single argument which is very easy
to do so for example for the
introduction itself if i said i want to
talk about why education in medicine is
important using this quote from richard
baineman that actually becomes a very
easy paragraph to write it's only going
to be a few sentences of me kind of
elaborating on this aim that i've
already made and i've done the same
thing everywhere so for example i'm
talking about the importance of using
imagery in education based on the fact
that there's the study that found that
using images improves learning so much
all i need to do is just elaborate on
that and add some extra words adverbs
and sentences it's not actually very
hard to do this honestly for me makes
writing endlessly easier and this part
usually takes me about an hour maximum
to do and when i am finally done with
this i feel super super relieved all i
do is take all the paragraphs that i've
written which are the actual essay
content and i put them together but at
this point i'm kind of blind to the
essay i have the same thing when i'm
working for something for a long time so
when i finish a painting i can't
actually see it normally and when i
finish an essay i can't actually see the
essay because i'm too used to the words
so i kind of need to take a break and a
few hours of this will do but a few days
is absolutely perfect depending on how
last minute this task has been left to
be so um i'll kind of step away from my
essay and i'll only come back to it
later and give it another half an hour
where i read through it make sure
everything makes sense i might rearrange
things delete or add some sentences here
and there and make sure it is all
coherent all my sources are already
listed so i can just copy and paste
those too and yep that is three hours of
work and a full essay done which has all
of the marking criteria sorted it has
all the resources there already it's
kind of creative because it has a bunch
of extra quotes and kind of fun things
in it it is structured well every single
paragraph is making a point which is
tied to the aim of the essay itself so
yeah it's kind of hard to go wrong using
this method so beyond the essay itself
this is actually a very special video
for me because it is my first notion
sponsorship and i am endlessly grateful
for them i knew during this video that i
wanted to do something related to
education because
um even though i have my completely
over-the-top uses for notion actually
it's just the best thing for students to
use in general and i thought that if i
were to make it a notion video it would
have to be for students so yeah here it
is i hope this made sense to anyone else
i'll be going back to university next
year so i will definitely be needing any
tips for essay writing and for studying
so if you have anything to share please
feel free to do so in the comments if
you haven't already signed up for notion
i'd be very surprised but there will be
a link in my description which will give
you free access to the app but otherwise
thank you so much for spending this time
with me i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day be kind to yourself and
others and don't believe everything you
think and loads loads of luck with your
essays in university bye